bonjour pour ce troisième jour de pages
étaient autour des sentiers de randonnée
et du patrimoine je vous emmène en berry
nous sommes sur le piton sancerre le
village préféré des français
et la boucle que je vous propose
aujourd'hui démarre au pied du piton au
niveau des caves de la mignonne pour
passer à chavignol amis et buée et nous
allons nous arrêter un petit peu abusé
pour vous raconter un peu l'histoire de
ce village de sorciers avec jean-marc
roblin président de l'association en
charge des nuits des sorciers qui se
déroulent en général la première semaine
d'août mais avant ça je vous propose de
découvrir un mets très locale le crottin
de chavignol et on se retrouve juste
après le sujet autour du piton de
sancerre c'est en l'air d'appellation du
crottin de chavignol amène tour at-elle
la ferme des chapeaux ton perpétue
depuis 40 ans la fabrication du célèbre
fromage
voilà allez allez et le cahier des
charges est très précis il détermine le
temps d'affinage l'alimentation aussi
bien que la race des chèvres c'est une
alpine donc marron avec le très noir sur
le dessus c'est dans le cahier des
charges du crottin de chavignol on n'a
pas le droit à l'ass annen qui est
blanche voilà c'est pour bien
différencier la race et en général à son
corps nu mais souvent on est obligé d
écorner propre à kas bat 65 % de
l'alimentation du cheptel doit se situer
dans la zone d'appellation contrôlée
ici les céréales pour nourrir les bêtes
sont produits sur place pour éviter de
trop acheté au voisin après la traite le
lait caillé et goûter est façonnée en
crottin tout un coup de main
une fois qu'on va des mollets lendemain
matin on va moule est ce que vous voyez
ici sur les tables donc ils sont sales
et un par un on les prend comme ceux ci
et on va ça l'est tout autour et on va
les retourner pour les retravailler
comme ça et les remettre comme ceux ci
les fromages sont déposés pour affinage
dans une cave à 10 degrés il faut savoir
que pour avoir droit à l'appellation
crottin de chavignol ces dix jours
d'affinage à partir du salage avant
et les fromages de chèvre voilà vous
voulez que je regarde si j'ai plus
affinée une centaine de producteurs
travaillent sur l'air d'appellation
chavignol 14 millions de crottin sont
vendus chaque année en france
après ce petit tour à la hausse et
chavignol nous sommes de retour à bué
avec jean marc rollin jean-marc roblin
et président de l'association en charge
de la nuit des sorciers mais pourquoi
une nuit des sorciers abus et bonjour et
bienvenue à peu et tout d'abord pourquoi
une nuit des sorcières il faut remonter
juste après la guerre en 1946 c'est le
curé du village de l'époque qui a voulu
lever des fonds pour construire une
salle afin de réunir la jeunesse et les
les habitantes b donc il s'est inspiré
de faits de de sorcellerie du qui
remonte au 16e siècle et ils ont décidé
d'appeler cette fête la foire aux
sorciers
c'est une fête champêtre avec un repas
champêtre des animations et une descente
aux flambeaux suivie pour qu'on dirait
jeu renouer avec la tradition si je puis
dire de brûler une sorcière donc les
pourquoi on brûle des sorciers ou des
sorcières abus et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il s'est passé donc je vous disais
fin du xvième siècle notamment en 1582
le fait le plus marquant de la
sorcellerie sur ab en sancerrois
c'est le procès de jean abordée alors
jean tabour des habitats but et ils
étaient laboureur de profession et il a
été dénoncé par des habitants du village
qui lui disait qu'il avait fréquenté le
diable et avait assisté à un sabbat au
caroux marlou on se trouve actuellement
40 marlou ça signifie le carrefour des
mauvais loue donc convié c'était à peu
près destinée donc que ils ont été lui
et quatre de ses camarades ont été jugés
ils ont été mis dans les géoles du
château de beaujeu quelques kilomètres
d'ici
1 et
le verdict du procès est tombée ils ont
donc été pendus et leurs cadavres a été
brûlé sur un bûcher érigé au cameroun
marlou tout s'est passé ici en fait
toute l'histoire s'est passé ici est
donc notre fête maintient le le comment
dirais-je le bûcher tous les ans on fait
brûler notre sorcière mais ça fait deux
ans en fait que alors vais pas faire
mais voilà on aurait dû fêter la 75e nu
des sorciers en août 2020 l'afld a été
en août 2021 et je pense que et j'espère
du fond du coeur et tous les habitants
de aussi tous les bénévoles pouvoir le
faire en l'an prochain quoi en 2022
eh ben on espère aussi pour vous faut en
tout cas merci monsieur merci beaucoup
merci de nous avoir raconté cette
légende très local d'ailleurs éloquent
merci merci pour merci à vous nous on se
retrouve demain pour notre dernière
journée de pages était sur les sentiers
de randonnée du patrimoine et on reste
en mairie